In the last series of lectures we considered the question of what is a patient
that naturally then prompts the question,
well,
what is the disease?
We offer classifications of disease that are based on evolutionary.
In mechanistic causation.
We do not see disease as being simply infectious or chronic or degenerative.
We see diseases having a finer,
more nuanced kind of a structure that relates boasts of its evolutionary origins
and to the kind of mechanisms that mediate its impact.
So these seven categories of disease are actually going to help us analyze
defenses,
maintenance and vulnerability.
The concepts are set up to connect to each other.
The first point to make is that the risk of disease varies with both genotype
and with environment.
The way that this graph is set up,
the x axis is just an array of genotypes.
The y axis is the risk of disease going from low to high and every point on the
red line represents the genotype and an associated disease risk.
And if you look across that,
it's a rather complex.
We've deliberately sketched a rather complex case environment.
D poses a risk of disease for almost all genotypes because virtually every point
on the line is above it.
So there's some risk of disease and Environment d for All of these genotypes.
But if we look at environment a,
it is posing a risk of disease only for those genotypes that are above that dash
line.
There all of the other genotypes are not at risk.
And this is a general picture.
This is something like this could be sketched for any real case for any real
disease.
So here are the seven categories
and this deliberately recognizes that the causation of diseases complex.
And at the outset I should say that some diseases belong to more than one
category and when that happens it indicates that they have complex causes.
So category one diseases or diseases with genetic causes.
Category two diseases with environmental causes.
Category three diseases that are byproducts of defense systems.
Category four or diseases of homeostasis.
Category five diseases that are caused by lack of maintenance.
Category six diseases caused by stochastic developmental problems.
And category seven are diseases of pregnancy and early development that are
caused by maternal fetal and maternal.
Paternal conflict.
So this is one of the more evolutionary of the causes as are the genetic causes.
So diseases that belong to more than one category have multiple causes and an
example is type two diabetes.
It is a disease both of homeostasis and of maintenance.
So category one,
genetic causation.
Genetic diseases are usually caused by mutations in single genes.
They cause disease in any environment and they are often lethal or they often,
if they're not lethal,
they prevent reproduction.
An example might be trisomy 21 here is trisomy 21 three copies of the 21st
chromosome,
cystic fibrosis,
severe combined immunodeficiency and thalassemia.
No specific mechanisms of evolved to protect us against these.
Their prevalence is increasing slightly.
His medical progress rescues cases that were previously lethal.
Category two environmental causation.
Yeah,
so is leading contributors to extrinsic mortality,
the environmental causes or driving natural selection and we have therefore
evolved mechanisms to deal with things like this.
There was a gradient going from catastrophic insulted affects all genotypes to
mild challenges that just affect a few genotypes that evokes that first
explanatory gene by environment slide.
They include infections,
dysbiosis,
starvation,
malnutrition,
dehydration,
hypoxia,
hyper and Hypo thermia mechanical injuries and exposure to Venoms,
toxins and pollutants.
So here's a case of starvation.
This is a survivor of the Andersonville concentration camp.
In the US civil war
is technology and culture reduce the prevalence of these kinds of diseases.
These they then increased the prevalence of the next category,
category three diseases.
Category three diseases are byproducts of defense systems.
They result from the cost of defense,
from deficient and excessive defense and for malfunctions of defense systems.
So these are vulnerabilities often exposed by environmental mismatches.
Many of them are ultimately caused evolutionarily by a conflict between survival
and reproduction.
On the one hand and health and wellbeing on the other,
their prevalence has increased is that of the category to environmental diseases
has declined and they include immunopathology,
these autoimmune diseases,
asthma,
fibrosis,
Metta plays you haemodynamic and from Thrombo,
embolic diseases,
obsessive compulsive disorder,
phobias,
paranoia,
anxiety and panic disorders.
All these can be seen as pro byproducts of defense systems.
Yeah.
Then there are the diseases of homeostasis.
They affect physiological systems that are designed to be plastic and
adjustable.
And this design intrinsically makes them vulnerable to dysregulation.
In part,
they result from inappropriate adjustment of homeostatic set points.
So homeostasis and plasticity both enabled diseases when the system is set and
locked in the wrong state,
they include obesity is the figure indicates type two diabetes,
atherosclerosis,
hypertension,
other cardiovascular diseases and addictive behavior.
They are often exposed by environmental mismatches.
Category five diseases are diseases of maintenance.
These are diseases that are not caused by the presence of some insult,
but by the absence of maintenance,
the decline of maintenance over time causes diseases of aging here evoked by the
contrast between an a healthy brain and the brain of someone with severe
Alzheimer's disease.
The diseases of aging affects structures and processes that are most in need of
maintenance and most costly to maintain.
These diseases are mediated by antagonistic ply a trophy.
If we focus on genetic causes and on trade offs,
if we focus on physiological causes.
Okay,
the increase in frequency when a drop in in extrinsic mortality extends
lifespan.
So this is one of the consequences of self domestication.
We extend lifespan and diseases of maintenance start to appear because our
bodies were not designed to keep us.
We'll maintain that long.
Okay.
Maintenance processes can prevent these diseases,
but there are no mechanisms in place to secure them once they begin,
so they can be prevented naturally,
but they cannot be cured naturally.
Yeah,
they include neurodegeneration,
Sarcopenia,
age related cancers,
type two diabetes and arthritis.
Okay.
Category six diseases are caused by stochastic developmental problems.
Problems.
They're either too rare or they're too expensive.
Revolution to fix.
They include trisomy 18 and 21 fetal hydrops diseases of premature delivery,
neonatal respiratory distress,
necrotizing Colitis,
jaundice,
and sudden infant death syndrome.
Sids.
Yeah.
Most diseases in this category are prevented by OCT nutrition and early
spontaneous abortions,
which are the quality control filters.
Some like Preeclampsia have complex causes and they also belong in category
seven so category seven includes diseases that are caused by disruptions of
equilibria in conflicts between relatives.
These include diseases of pregnancy such as Preeclampsia or gestational diabetes
of early development,
including abnormal birth weights,
just station times and of blood group incompatibilities.
They may also contribute to,
but they're not solely responsible for their causation of mental disorders that
include autism and schizophrenia.
Something we'll return to when we discuss mental disorders.
Now diseases can be viewed from four perspectives.
The first is the patient's perspective.
The disease is a state of not feeling well.
There's pain,
nausea,
fatigue,
discomfort and depression.
Okay.
The physician's perspective is that a disease consists of abnormal conditions
that produce symptoms compromising patient health who's causes are then sought
so that they can be corrected.
The evolutionary perspective of a pathogen is that a disease can produce
symptoms in the host that promoters reproduction or transmission or they can be
unintended byproducts of its interaction with the host.
Okay?
Yeah.
Evolutionary perspective of the host is that a disease can be a byproduct of
prior natural selection.
It can be a substrate for current natural selection,
v effects on reproductive success or it can be a defense mechanism in action,
so all diseases can be viewed from all four perspectives.
All diseases also have both mechanistic and evolutionary explanations.
They are not completely understood until both types of explanation has been
given.
For example,
Crohn's disease,
which presents with abdominal pain,
diarrhea and weight loss.
A mechanistic explanation would use the language of genetics development,
the biochemistry of nod receptors,
regulatory t cells,
and the anti inflammatory cytokine ill 10
and evolutionary explanation would talk about mismatch caused by modern hygiene
leading to dysbiosis of a perturbed Microbiota,
focusing probably on a lack of worms.
Both types of explanation contain clues for treatment and we can't really see
why the disease exists the way it does until we have worked through both
no genetic and environmental causes of disease or each of two types.
Genetic causes can be defects or predispositions,
so defects are the category one.
Diseases such as cystic by process predispositions on the other hand are often
poly genic rather than monogenic and are involved more often in environmental
interactions.
Environmental causes can be either catastrophic or a cumulative.
Catastrophes include Predator attacks and infections with highly virulent
pathogens like SARS,
Mers,
Ebola.
Accumulative effects occur with things like smoking,
overeating,
and lack of exercise,
which affect risks of cardiovascular disease,
cancer,
and type two diabetes.
So the differentiation between sudden large effects and then continued smaller
accumulative effects is important both for genes and for the environment.
Here is an example of an accumulative environmental effect.
What do you see here is the risk,
the adjusted odds ratio over here on the y axis
of developing peripheral arterial disease as a function of the amount of second
hand smoke and countered in the environment.
So this is hours of exposure per week to second hand smoke and you can see that
up to about 20 hours a week.
It's not making too much difference,
but from that point on it climbs and it's actually climbing exponentially,
so it's curving upward on a regular graph.
This is an exponential access over here and increased exposure to secondhand
smoke is causing increased risk of peripheral arterial disease.
That is a standard kind of accumulative environmental effect.
Many of the genetic effects on disease are in fact mediated by interactions with
the environment and we refer to that as g by e gene by environment.
Causation?
No.
When a disease is caused by an interaction,
it is a mistake to assign responsibility to just one component of the
interaction.
The important effects are actually tied up in the interaction.
So the environmental risks of cancers such as tobacco and air pollution depend
on genotype the see that.
Let's revisit the example of variation in an asset deal transferees that we saw
in a previous lecture.
A good example of the interactions of genes and environment in determining
disease risk is that of the steel transfer races and cancer risk.
We saw that with bladder cancer where those with the combination of the nat two
slow Acetylator,
the nat one fastest settled later and current or ever cigarette smoking,
we're 2.7 times more likely to get bladder cancer for colorectal cancer.
Smoking intensity,
increased cancer risk among carriers have both in 81 n a t two fastest subtle
leaders much more than in those who did not have those
and for pancreatic cancer,
the nat one polymorphism interacts with dietary mutagenic intake.
For example,
barbecued meat to increase the risk of pancreatic cancer two and a half times in
men,
but not in women.
So to evoke those associations here we have smoking associated with colon cancer
and barbecuing associated with these light liver,
Mata,
uh,
liver metasticies coming from the pancreas visualized here against the darker
red background of the section deliver.
To summarize,
we placed diseases into seven categories that have both mechanical and
evolutionary causes.
Genetic causes can act either catastrophic Lee or through predispositions,
environmental causation connect either catastrophic Lee or through a cumulative
effects.
Many diseases result from g by e interactions that are missing in the classical
disease categories
important g by e interactions often occur when genetic effects are apologetic
and environmental effects or accumulative.
And depending on the causation,
organisms either evolved defense mechanisms to protect themselves against the
disease maintenance mechanisms to help prevent disease,
or in some cases,
no such mechanisms at all.